[Music]  there are rumors rumors I tell you that  the next pope could be an American  Cardinal Sean O'Malley from Boston  that's right he could become the next  pope of course if that happened he'd be  the first American Pope in history the  first yeah  an American Pope would mean big changes  at Vatican City first would see a much  cooler Pope at you know that night yeah  we would see a slightly different  popemobile I think it at a flat-screen  TV to the Sistine Chapel I think it'd be  good idea Pitt make Dave Matthews a  saint ladies night and finally an  American Pope would rename st. Peter's  Basilica  Verizon's the Christ zone  [Applause]  what are we doing what are we doing what  are we really doing is this really the  best use of our time and blaming them  for my foolishness what's why was all  you